the one thing that I'm not afraid of
isn't I've learned not afraid of my
emotions and I'm not afraid to let them
let you see him I mean I'm an actor if I
can I'm afraid of that I should be doing
something else right so I I think I've
heard that I'm fearless so that makes me
feel good because I think actors don't
get enough credit to do what we do and
to be really good at it you have to be
fearless and like people always worried
about all the ways you know if I go
there how are they gonna perceive me
well if I'm gonna be an emotion I'm an
emotional guy by nature I'm just a
sensitive person and I was very afraid
of that when I first came to LA cuz I
just wanted to be like the rough guy and
my acting coach she says listen to me
John I know you think you want to be you
know the tough guy and the cop who goes
out and kills everyone he says but I'm
gonna tell you something the role that
you're gonna get recognized for is the
one where you're willing to let them see
how sensitive you are and I had to let
that in I was like I brushed it aside
but I had to let that and then
eventually I started finding that yeah
you know I'm I'm effective all and I'm
emotional and I you know my feelings run
deep and so yeah so I learned to be
comfortable with that and I think he's
been doing it for 50 years I think he
might you know might have a little more
insight than I do so do you think also -
aside from being emotional and and being
you know having some strong feelings
running deep because you had this other
life and because you saw your mom that
time that that really like gave you this
thing that said no this is this is here
and life isn't forever and I need to do
this yeah it the experience that I had
man I get emotional thinking about it
the experience I had watch him my mom
died
got prepared me for everything like this
is a woman who was my best friend you
know I talked to her like three times a
day or on the phone she and I would take
vacations together and we would do
everything together and like so to see
her in the in this hospice dying and it
was nothing I could do to help her
you know other than you know hold her
hand or nothing in life could be could
be that hard and I think everything is
ammunition for some role that you'll
have and you know you always have you
always have something to pull from you
know and that's what life is about right
it's like you live this experience I'm a
method actor and so like everything
becomes something for you grab bag for
later on so it might not be a role where
my mom is dying but it could be my kid
or it could be you know a woman who
plays my whitey for a friend or you know
so everything is everything is
experience for everything and just one
are you willing to use it and to do you
have the ability to access it and are
you going to let the audience see you be
I think people will say you know being
emotional makes you weak I completely
disagree I think being emotional and
being one to show it makes you very
strong
you